it's always not just about the
technology it's like having the support
of you know all the leadership in the
company and being able to learn from
them of like you know how to build and
scale the business that was i think a
unique opportunity for me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about engineering
with avigolan vice president of
engineering and general manager of
israel at ziprecruiter
avigolan is zip recruiter israel general
manager and vice president of
engineering leading the israel
engineering site with a data-driven
focus on delighting both job seekers and
employers and fundamentally improving
the hiring experience
prior to joining ziprecruiter avi is a
membrane alumnus and served in an
intelligence unit avi has over two
decades of experience in the software
industry building and leading r d
organizations
let's get started avi welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
being here how are you good good thank
you for inviting me to the show really
excited to be here thank you very much
thank you for coming vice president of
engineering and general manager of zip
recruiter in israel uh five or six years
ago you founded the the r d site here in
israel for this multinational company
zip recruiter
working with people all over the world
to to connect them with with relevant
jobs and so there's obviously very very
relevant to today's marketplace very
relevant to the different questions that
are that are being asked today and we'll
focus also on zip recruiter and and i'd
love for you to start by telling me a
little bit about what you do there but
but afterwards i'd love to really dig
deep into what it means to to to create
this r d site here in tel aviv and be
and act as vice president of engineering
for this multinational company so so
what is ziprecruiter in a few words
so zip recorder is an online employment
marketplace we basically connect between
the two sides uh the job seekers and the
employment or the employers of the jobs
um and we're actively working in order
to make those connections across
industries cross-verticals where like
support we're helping
nurses and truck drivers and engineers
and data scientists and marketers and
like every basically every uh occupation
and every industry we're uh able to you
know find the right opportunity uh as a
job seeker and find the right talent as
an employer uh we're uh supporting both
smbs like it can be like you know small
pizza shop that is looking for uh
delivery drivers or cashiers and it
could be like you know large enterprises
that are looking for
10 000 warehouse workers um and we do
that with a lot of you know ai and smart
matching technology that we built based
on the large uh data
um
over uh the last
10 or 11 years since the company was
founded we
we had more than 800 million job
applications through our platform also
many people that pressed apply and
submitted their resume
which is you know huge
uh huge impact on on like you know in
the industry mainly
uh operating in the u.s market but also
uh uh
in europe
unbelievable and so yeah five or six
years ago you you set out to create the
r d site here in israel join us vp
engineering
of zip recruiter walk me through the
rationale of of taking this
multinational company and deciding to
open a new r d site here in tel aviv and
then what was that like from your
perspective coming in as the general
manager
yeah
so um i think uh uh the story of
ziprecruiter is is slightly unique
versus the other multinational that you
see here
that open
engineering sites
so the company was founded in 2010 it
was uh bootstrap till
and then it raised
serious a
and um in order to grow like that's that
was like you know the the founders
decided that they want to take the
company to the next level
um and
as part of that
um they like you know acknowledge that
they need like stronger and and and
bigger
engineering organization
um and
they made the decision to open an
engineering site in israel in tel aviv
and before jeff's wedding so he founded
a company before that that was uh
the name of the company was competitor
it was sold to aol and it had an
engineering site here in tel aviv and it
worked for him um and he joined the
paper after that uh as the ceo and
decided to replicate that um and
decide that he needs someone to you know
to to be
you know employee number one to start
the office and and like to start
uh uh um
being hands-on and like solving issues
but also like scaling and and and and
hiring and recruiting and growing and
you know solving problems um so
you know we
uh
connected you know over like you know it
was
skype back then
but it was like wow it was i never met
anyone in person like now it seems
right you like in yeah interviews
it's like you know that's that's that's
how you do interviews right
but it was back then it's like 2015 it
was
like i met with the founders met with
jeff met with a couple of technical
people and then you know decided to make
this leap of faith i guess of like you
know there's this amazing company that
is looking for
you know for uh um to do this major
growth and scaling and and it was an
amazing opportunity as like a career
growth
as well as like you know solving
problems now walk me through a little
bit about your you know
cognitively what's going on in your mind
you're tasked with starting this new r d
team what what is top of mind for you is
it scaling the team is it getting more
responsibility with a product
is it getting trust
from you know your counterparts around
the world that are now looking to see
what you come up with
what what really you know bothers you
during that time or what occupies you
yeah probably everything that you
mentioned um i was like
no one told me like this is what we want
you to do or this is those are the
problems that we want you or the team to
solve it's like
it was uh um
you know we have you know amazing
company that we build um a lot of
customers that are using the you know
the product both on the on the consumer
side the job seekers and the employer
side
you know both b2b and b2c
um and
we have a lot of data we have a lot of
like challenges and opportunities and
like
you know try
uh uh to figure out where you can
provide value basically that was like
you know um that was the uh
the mission statement um and
and that was like i was obsessed about
like finding where i can can provide
value and like you know bringing
my previous experience in in attack and
and other like big data um
um um technologies that that i had over
the the
20-something years
in the software industry
um so
really
just talking to people trying to
understand like you know where are like
the challenges where are the
opportunities
understanding the you know the ecosystem
the the market itself and like uh um
what kind of technology right is out
there um and and i think that's like the
the major challenge and it's i remember
the first days where it's like
you know
you you're alone
um i took like uh you know uh like a
shared space in mind space in in uh in
gold shield uh so
just not to be alone right it's just
just to see people so i had this uh
this uh
small office back then
um and
and like talking to people in my early
morning and then in the evenings
um and digging up in the data you know
looking
um going into the data where i was
looking in
in uh um
you know the vast amount of data that we
collected and then
trying to zoom in on the areas where we
uh where we could
we like eventually it was we like after
a few months like we grow and i you know
hired some you know some of my past
colleagues and friends
um and they brought their friends um
and and now we're about 80 people but
back then it was like
like two three
you know the end of the year it was six
unbelievable um
and we we started by solving like one of
the hardest problems of of matching it's
like how can you provide a better
experience for both the job seeker and
the employer
um by you know
harnessing ai like using the data that
we you know collected over the years and
and building models that can learn
uh um like what's a good match like
um how
how do you qualif how um how a recruiter
sees like you know the resume of uh
you know a nurse versus the resume of a
software engineer and like what's
important for for each recruiter or
what's important for the job seeker um
and then like you know teaching model or
building models that can understand that
uh based on the data and based on like
the you know the
the talent and engineers and data
scientists that we uh have in the
company so if you're fast forwarding to
today now with over 80 people on your
team in the site here in israel and
you're obviously making a big impact on
the multinational company that has many
many more people than that in it yeah
you know what what do you think worked
along the journey what were some things
that you either prioritized or by chance
happened that that made this a smooth
transition and and
pretty a pretty fast growth you know 80
people over the span of five six years
yeah
um so i think
you know we proved ourselves we created
value we found the areas where we
internally uh where we
yeah like you know or you know created
value for the company right create a
developer for our customers and i think
we we proved that that you know we can
you know tech take the challenges or or
even come up with innovation and the
things that can you know can help the
company scale and can have the company
like
uh we can talk about that later but we
ipo three uh months ago so it's like
taking the company really to the next
level um and and um and i think this is
like you know for me i'm um
very much focused on creating like
finding areas where we can create the
value and focusing on that
um and and
and and then scaling and then like you
know once we found like product market
fit
internally and externally like once we
verify that this is like a problem worth
solving um and then we're like you know
we're all in we're like we'll you know
we'll grow the the team will
um uh will you know get alignment from
the entire organization and so on so i
think that's
you know that that was the major factor
that i think helped us um
like building the relationship one of
the challenges was like you know this
um we have like one platform once one
company right it's like it's not like uh
yeah i don't know like uh
like a a big company that that that
opens um
an r d side that
develops like a small feature or small
truck or or a small big doesn't matter
but like a
like a product that that can be
encapsulated um
and have like clear interfaces was more
of a how can we build an organization
um that
that can have engineers or can have data
scientists or people and product
managers people from both sides of the
world like working closely together and
we have managers here that manage people
uh you know uh
in l.a and and vice versa right
um so that was like one of the biggest
challenges how to bring this to build
this culture and to build this
organization over the years really what
we're you know things we're talking
about you know building culture scaling
a team creating value internally and
externally i mean it really sounds like
we're talking about you know you created
almost you know as an entrepreneur
creating a company creating a startup
within a startup having many of those
same challenges that that a traditional
founder has you're doing it within this
multinational but but it's
entrepreneurship uh you know with
by any standard right
yeah exactly without like you know
without the the need to be uh uh uh you
know obsessive like you know how to get
uh how to pay salaries next month right
you know how to to get the next uh
funding uh so i was fortunate to have
this opportunity of of really doing that
that's like uh founding like uh you know
a new company
uh um
and and like
being able to recruit like top tenants
you know bring on
uh um
very talented people that can
help me do that you know scaling and do
that growth and and creating value right
um so it's it's it's a lot easier when
you have like you know you have the
support
uh um of of like amazing you know
amazing amazing uh um
leaders in the in the organization right
it's like people that
it's it's usually not just about the
technology or like yeah
it's always not just about the
technology it's like having the support
of uh um
uh um of you know all the leadership in
the company of uh um and and being able
to learn from them of like you know how
to to build and scale
um the business that was uh i think a
unique opportunity for me 100
now talk to me a little bit about what
you learned you know over these five six
years you've sort of become an expert
and ai expert in in matching
technologies and what works and what
doesn't work with you know looking for
jobs matching for jobs i either as a
seeker or as an employer what are some
baseline ideas that perhaps may not even
be that trivial for for the common
person that's applying for a job or
writing their resume what are some
things that you've learned through your
experiences that that we can share with
it with anybody that's listening
yeah so um
so what one of like uh before i answer a
question one one of the learnings that
that i had um like early on was like
it's
as as as a company and organization it's
it's um
it's not just about the technology it's
lot you know it's it's you can build
this amazing ai and a major amazing
technology
but like you you know
it's it's the business it's the
organization it's a product it's a
marketing it's like a combination of all
of the those
that are working together in order to
get you know the company to the next
level
yeah um and then like on the on the
matching side
um so if you're uh
if you're like you know someone that is
now
on the market or or planning to go uh uh
to start finding jobs and like applying
to jobs um
you need to understand that the uh the
landscape has changed in terms of um
um the the the
the flow of of who reads your resume or
right how to get past like to to the
next level it's like it used to be like
a pile of uh you know you always see
this picture of a pile of like a
thousand resumes sitting on someone's
desk it's now like
it's automated right obviously right
and
a lot of uh um
i think a lot of people just don't
understand that that in order to get to
the recruiter you need to pass some some
bot some ai um
that scans your resume and and try to
extract the date and it's it's trying to
extract the data from it right it's like
trying to understand your previous
experience your um your education and so
on and if what does that mean in terms
of the what does that mean in terms of
the focus because if the focus before
needed to be on you know standing out i
remember you know applying to college
you have to stand out so that your
college application is you know
different not necessarily even better
but just different than that of the
thousands of others that they have on
their desk now i'm assuming that you
actually have to be a little bit more
intentional and specific to the role
perhaps that you're applying to
yeah so
so keep in mind that you know those ai
that scans your your resume first needs
to understand right so like it can be
uh uh like right you know don't use uh
uh tables and fancy formatting and like
stuff like that that will you know in
some cases you know the the um the
machine will fail to read the resumes
and and it will just reduce your chances
in like in getting to the next level so
like
you know
try to focus on or try to
to to
to write like the
uh um the most um
simple format that you can you can still
like describe your achievements and so
on but but don't use you know fancy
words or obviations that no one knows or
something that you know describes
try to you know try to uh
uh
put some fancy words around stuff that
you do it's like right again the the
machine is trying to extract the skills
that you know and if it doesn't
understand or if you're writing in a
unique way that you didn't see before
that's like it's it will be more
difficult to
uh to get past this you know to get past
this stage and like this there's this uh
um
you know myth i don't know if or
our um common knowledge about
recruiter spends like six seconds
reading your resume six or seven seconds
really passing through your resume
yeah in in many cases you don't even get
that it's like there's like a snippet
right that they see it's like you know
it's like right they depends on like the
role but you have roles where where
hundreds of people apply and you have
like a like um
uh um like a summary of your you know
past experience education skill set and
and so on
and it's like again if it fails to fail
to understand that then you're basically
shooting yourself into that
so what i'm hearing you what i'm
extracting from this and they take away
from me is you know if before you know
the traditional advice would be to stand
out be different make something that
will that will force the the decision
maker to take a closer look and be
intrigued by what you do here we're
actually going for simplicity stick to
the rules make you know this the the
more common you are in the in the format
the better you are served because the
better chances you that you will be
understood by the algorithm but then
you know the more specific you are also
an intentional then then the more likely
you'll be matched with a position that
that really fits you and i think that
that's uh you know definitely something
that i'm taking away and that i think
that anybody that's listening it's
relevant for everybody now i do want to
take you back abby really quickly in the
last few minutes that we have a little
bit about you share with me both you
know what really fascinated you as a kid
but also what inspires you today
okay um so
yeah growing up i was uh um uh like ever
since i remember myself i was like i
wanted to be a doctor it's like i i grew
up to a mother that was a nurse
like you know 50 years as a nurse or
something like that like 40 something
years
and like we live right next to the
hospital and like i remember myself like
after school
it's like a you know first of second
grade going to eat lunch with her at
like at the hospital like i was
fascinated about this
about uh uh
you know this occupation and and and
up till the age of like
you know 17 uh i was sure that this is
what i'm going to do uh started but
biology
like
high school
but but then you know life takes uh some
turns and um
um i was like in the army i was
recruited to mamaram and did like
the programming training
um and and fell in love with uh you know
uh this uh domain and the software
industry
um
and you know and my life changed since
then so i'm grateful for that
opportunity and the rest is history and
i think uh um and to your second
question about what's fascinating uh
what inspiring me today is it's like
it's it's it's going back to creating
value it's like how can we harness
technology and to solve you know market
deficiencies problems
uh um
um
things that that you know looking back
five or ten years ago
were not stoppable would uh or were
much harder to solve than than today
with the technology that we have using
ai and big data um so i'm fascinated by
that it's like seeing this the
technology how it's like
how it uh um
progress and and helps solving like you
know we're basically using the
technology to solve like the the most
basic human needs of like finding a job
helping people that really need
you know support really need guidance
really need uh how our help to to to
understand where you know their next
opportunity might be like there's
there's a stat that we're we're using uh
that we have that you know we have like
two uh two boxes on the on in the
homepage it's like what are you looking
for and where it's like 13
don't even know what to look for
it's like they put jobs or i need a job
or blank
and it's like it's interesting it's our
role it's our mission to help guide them
um and help them understand user
technology using like the fact that
we've seen millions of people with the
same education with the same skill set
with the same period trajectory
we are able to provide that kind of
guidance and that kind of help and
support so i so that's fascinating
i love it and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
i think a lot of
like a lot of the things that i
described is technology so technology is
one and innovation
uh slash value
using innovation and and i think also
family i'm trying to balance between the
between like work and life so
very very cool
i love it avi i really want to thank you
this was fantastic i loved the insights
the stories both on you know the
recruiting and the hiring and and and
understanding the transition that we've
made from manual to automated and what
you know what what we need to derive
from that for both the seekers and also
the the employers but then you know
opening a new site for a multinational
company vpr d and and
then distilling it to creating value and
in just as big of an entrepreneurial
journey so thank you very much for the
time and inspiration and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you really enjoy that
bye
[Music]